well they in their wisdom
came to me to host this show
they're very wise people
we embrace all the demographics all the
generations yes uh the current members
of aarp are also the original fans of
star trek
but they brought their children of right
their children are fast approaching
aarp membership and like their parents
they are sci-fi fans
and
they are also approaching aarp age so we
embrace them but the original fans also
have
grandchildren
many of them are
extremely fluent in social media
but that's the
stereotype image that the grandchildren
are fluent in social media but the
grandparents are not not true we had an
episode on
on online dating
and did you know
that uh members of the aarp and that
their demographic their generation
are the fastest growing users of
the of social media for online dating
because
many people have gotten divorced
or
unhappily are widowed
and we have longer lives lifespans now
and they want to
live a full
rich life with a companion or maybe even
a spouse and so you know we we want
uh the ones who are
the current members of aarp
to to be uh
well-informed uh
uh hit
if they if you will on technology and
what's trending
but we want a younger demographic also
to be aware of
aarp and all the various
services and opportunities that the
uh
the association
gives that
you know i think we all say oh my when
you when you see
something wonderful
or something you know shocking oh my you
know or uh when a man landed on the moon
when uh neil armstrong landed oh my you
know aw you know it's a common everyday
phrase and i've been using it all the
time
my fatal mistake
was going on the howard stern show
and
he asked a woman
to take her bra
and i said oh my
and
even more oh my
she did
and it was oh my oh my
and he had the oh my on tape
so whether i'm there or not whenever
someone does something outrageous or
says something outrageous he presses a
button and my voice comes on saying oh
my
and that's how it came to be my
signature phrase i had nothing to do
with it it's all that rascal howard
stern
you can call me takai if you want to
okay and many people have okay and i
explained to them and then they
immediately switched it to cave because
takai
means expensive
and i'm very accommodating
i'd be more than happy to send you a uh
voucher
live long and prosper and subscribe to
tk's tape